tenemos la ecuación menos 16 igual a x
entre 4 + 2 y queremos resolver esta
ecuación con respecto a x esto lo que
significa es dejar a la x sol y está
completamente solita de un lado del
igual y un bonche de cosas del otro lado
del igual ok esto es justo lo que vamos
a hacer ahorita ahora para lograrlo un
paso intermedio podría ser dejar x entre
4 solito de un lado del igual y para
hacer eso simplemente tenemos que
deshacernos de este + 2 y la mejor forma
de hacerlo es restando 1 2
ok porque 2 menos dos es igual a cero
entonces ya nos deshicimos del 2 y nos
queda simplemente x entre 4 de este lado
del igual pero hay un detalle muy
importante aquí y eso es que esto de
aquí es una ecuación este signo de igual
significa que lo que está de este
es exactamente igual a lo que está de
este lado y si le restamos 2 a este el
lado del igual a fuerzas tenemos que
restar 2 de este lado del igual porque
esta es una ecuación y queremos que el
lado izquierdo siga siendo igual al lado
derecho entonces siempre que tenemos una
ecuación y queremos modificarla todo lo
que le hagamos a un lado del igual se lo
tenemos que hacer también al otro bueno
entonces vamos a continuar aunque hay de
este lado lo que tenemos es menos 16 más
menos 2 eso es
-18 y esto de aquí va a ser igual a esta
cosa que es x cuartos x entre 4 y luego
más 2 menos 2 y eso es simplemente 0 de
hecho aquí podría poner un + 0 pero pues
creo que no es necesario ok entonces ya
dejamos a x cuartos solito de un lado
del igual ya estamos más cerca de dejar
solito a x ya nada más nos falta
deshacernos de este 1 entre 4 y bueno la
mejor forma de hacer eso es
multiplicando por cuatro ok entonces
aquí vamos a multiplicar por 4 y como
estamos en una ecuación entonces también
tenemos que multiplicar por 4 de este
lado del igual ok para que este lado
siga siendo igual a este otro y entonces
si tenemos aquí algo que se divide entre
4 y luego lo multiplicamos por cuatro
realidad no le estamos haciendo nada a
esta cosa cierto este entre 4 y luego
por 4 se cancelan y por aquí lo que nos
queda es a ver tenemos 18 y estamos
multiplicando por cuatro
eso es 4 por 8 32 2 y llevamos 34 por 14
más 3
7 entonces 18 por 4 72 pero aquí tenemos
menos 18 que tenemos menos 18 entonces
esto es menos 72 así es que esta cosa de
aquí es igual a menos 72 y eso es igual
a esta x solita equis y listo ya
terminamos x es igual a menos 72 ahora
estaría muy bien poder checar nuestras
respuestas y lo bueno es que hay una
forma muy fácil de hacerlo lo único que
tenemos que hacer es tomar la ecuación
original de esta ecuación de aquí y
sustituir la equis ok buscar en esta
ecuación todos los lugares donde aparece
la equis y en lugar de poner la x vamos
a poner menos 72 para ver la ecuación
original
-16 igual a x que es menos 72 entre 4
más
si en efecto se da esta igualdad
entonces esta respuesta es correcta
ahora menos 16 igual nosotros sabemos
por esta multiplicación que menos 72
entre 4 es igual a menos 18 entonces
aquí tenemos menos 18 más 2 y menos 18
más 2 desigualdad menos 16 menos 16 - 16
entonces esta igualdad si es cierta y
por lo tanto esta igualdad también es
cierta y entonces x si es igual a menos